joining us now former president Trump's
legal spokesman now legal spokeswoman uh
Elena Hoppers
legal analyst Gregory
it'll look happy in that mug shot I'll
say that and and who would be happy this
is now the fourth time that this has
happened this is unprecedented we've
never had a former president ever
indicted we never had a cheap political
rival of of the opposition party ever
you know treated like this before you
look at the the case let's analyze it
from a legal standpoint sure or it's
garbage how about a very plain simple
English standpoint when you have the
president whose sole responsibility is
to take care of America the Constitution
election interference and make sure that
we are the America that I used to know
not the America you and I know now
um and he is then prosecuted because he
is leading so significantly frankly in
the polls that he doesn't even need to
go on a debate this is the the crisis
that we're in as American people there
is no case unfortunately we have library
books Sean we have uh bookkeeping
because they didn't like the category on
the QuickBooks tab that he put on a
legal expense and then we have this
which is him doing his job as the
President of the United States frankly
something we haven't seen for several
years since Biden's been in the
administration and they're going to try
and put him in prison because they can't
beat him let's talk about and by the way
how do you get four trials in during a
primary season into a general election
season it would be an impossibility for
my standpoint right now in the case of
this RICO case it the obligation to
prove intent is critical right on all of
these charges in other words that the
defendant acted with the intention of
committing a crime or a fraud uh I would
bet every penny I had that if you gave
Donald Trump a lie detector test and you
asked him whether he believed everything
that he was saying uh the answer would
be a thousand percent yes and yet we
have these historically we've had other
slates of electors brought forward how
did this happen and how do you prove
intent Greg Jarrett well I don't think
he can in this particular case proving a
criminal State of Mind means that the
district attorney has to prove that
Donald Trump was aware that what he was
doing was unlawful everything we know
about his conduct leading up to the
certification of electors is that he
thought he was availing himself properly
of the legal process and exhibit a and
this is the most exculpatory for the
president is his conversation with the
Secretary of State uh in Georgia in
which he is complaining uh about ballot
irregularities a faulty machines uh
valid votes that aren't being counted
invalid votes that are being counted
election laws that are being violated
petitions that are being ignored and in
the end he is demanding a recount and a
review which by the way Brad
raffensberger has a duty to do so he's
asking him do your duty Fanny Willis
who's misrepresented and lied in an
earlier filing about what Donald Trump
said claiming he said you need to find
11 780 votes that's not what he said
read the transcript or listen to the
conversation long trans right and in
that transcript at times he's talking
about there are hundreds of thousands of
votes that you guys got wrong he is
saying I need to find that many votes
because that is my vote deficit well
every losing candidate says that which
is why they ask for reviews
recalculations and recounts it's
perfectly lawful it is not Criminal
Intent all right Elena let me ask you
this
um in the case in Washington they want
to start the trial on January 2nd
interesting in Georgia they want to
start on March 4th okay that's a Monday
on Tuesday the next day that would be
called super Tuesday one of the most
important primary days for anybody that
is running for president
um
is there any possible way you foresee
that he can run a presidential race be
tried on four separate uh have four
separate trials and successfully compete
or
you know does they just take his time
away as a candidate and he's good luck
to him and who cares well that's exactly
right and quite honestly Sean that's not
even the full picture we have Leticia
James let's not forget her she's about
as sick a ticket as Jack Smith and the
rest of them she ran on a platform to
get one man Donald Trump one
organization the Trump organization one
family the Trump family right that's
right so you have DA's and AGS who are
now able to come out and say I want to
get Donald Trump and elect me on that
cause and I'm going to do it then they
do it so we have October Leticia James
we have January e Gene Carroll then we
have the criminal indictment don't
forget those those are all by Design so
everything is the judges can't move they
don't want to move and they want a
speedy trial but they've had years and
years and years to investigate these
cases but they didn't bring it until now
and now they need a speedy trial it's
political interfere and election
interference you believe that two and a
half years they waited real quick oh
absolutely now they want the first trial
to happen in in two months but what
Elena just said is really important it's
a violation of the canonism of Ethics
that govern prosecutors to campaign on a
promise of putting a specific individual
Behind Bars their duty is to see that
Justice is done not to gain a conviction
uh based on their own Ambitions and
desire to advance their career but
that's what Fanny Willis has done
Leticia James as well as Alvin Bragg all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else